y at il de la triche dans the voice
quelques jours cette question semble
être posée par de plus en plus
d'internautes médusés en cause une
petite phrase de jennifer coach de
l'émission qui ne passe pas alive 21
c'est lors de la prestation de wild
arber que l'événement s'est produit
alors que les coaches faisait tous d'eau
à l'artiste et qui n'avait pas encore
chanté jane hyper a lancé une petite
phrase qui a laissé les téléspectateurs
pantois
une information qu'elle n'aurait pas dû
détenir puisqu'elle était retourné
immédiatement les réseaux se sont
enflammés comment jennifer a pu savoir
que le chanteur avait un chapeau alors
qu'elle ne l'avait pas vu et que c'était
à la veuve si beaucoup ont parlé de
tricherie un internaute a tenté de
trouver une explication selon lui il
existe des ro fait dans lesquelles les
couches peuvent distinguer plus ou moins
bien la silhouette de celles et ceux qui
chantent une hérésie pour une émission
dont le concept est justement de juger
des candidats à l'aveuglé
ont d'autres l'explication est ailleurs
alors je voyais seule star accusé de
triche si j'y crois
je ne crois pas mais je vais il ya deux
personnes qui pensent que oui alors il
ya magali bernard
le bascala d'abord honneur qu au dos
dames pardon des barbares je suis sous
le choc non vraiment c'est une
catastrophe elle aurait pu savoir qu'ils
avaient un chapeau non mais vous pouvez
tous dire non mais on sait comment elle
aurait plus à
l est allé en face en fait du public qui
à attendre et muni
intelligente et pas comment quatre bras
lorsque cécile
gallez qu'est ce que tu fais jennifer et
reconnaît à chaque fois c'est une
information et styliste que je vous
donne à mais elle les reconnaît à chaque
fois tu peux reprendre tous les pays
comme on dit vérité c'est pas exclusif
magali regard j'ai eu tout à l'heure
j'ai amené le producteur qui nous
embrasse d'ailleurs benji la pathétique
de l'émission de débat que je tenais une
explication très concrète et très simple
clairement ils sont retournés il n'y a
donc pas publics il ya des écrans avec
des boucles de public et à ce moment là
effectivement il n'y avait pas dans
l'écran la boucle de public il n'y avait
tout simplement un reflet comme on peut
le comprendre tant d'années au wawel a
vu très légèrement derrière un mec avec
le chat pour les licornes et pour un
très bon et je vais te dire autre genre
je pense quand même que ce vol s'ils
sont suffisamment intelligente on se
dire que s'il y avait quoi que ce soit
de celle où il aurait
juré qu elle en est là c'est avant
l'argument est dans l'émission
enregistré un joli sourire on va se
tirer une balle dans le pied oui
expliquez moi quelque chose ce qui est
valable par exemple pour les 12 coups de
midi d'accord on se dit c'est peut-être
préparer parce que c'était un joueur
préparer n'ai pas triché attention
produit on va dire mais la prod genre
bon on prépare les choses etc c'est un
jeu faut donc on fait gagner cac et
c'est pourquoi ça serait pas valable
dans the voice pourquoi il aurait
peut-être pas une oreillette parce
qu'alain qui est plus fort et qu'il faut
faire ta ta ta ta j'ai fait un jeu à
l'époque qui s'appelle sarah kazemy on
savait pertinemment la production aussi
qui allait être la finaliste cetc il
faut où il faut une fausse direction et
ce sont des jouets mais après je vous
arrête sur le couple ne s'est pas
déplacée n'avait pas de réflexion je
vous explique pourquoi parce que dans la
star ac est un exemple un contre exemple
qui a les qualités balle à magalie vaé
où toute la chaîne et la production ne
savait plus comment faire pour s'en
débarrasser pour les mauvaises raisons
parce qu'effectivement il enrichit
malterie sur un débarras elle
ressemblait pas aux standards qu'ils
avaient généré pas se mentir pour be
pour la gagnante ils ont tout fait pour
faire les magnétos à charles paul yonnet
des pires chansons il fallait jamais
marché et ça je crois pas aux revanches
est sûr c'est que on sait dans cette
émission là que j'ai présentées vous le
savez avec la l'évoquent qui sont qui
évolue chaque semaine nous on connaît
les tendances on connaît tous les
penseurs tous de tous les candidats donc
c'est très bien celui qui est toujours
en tête donc on sait très bien ce qu'ils
rares être aussi un petit peu à l'arrêt
voilà ce qu'on sait c'est bien ça
j'espère que nos regards des gagnants de
the voice envers leur profil bas je te
le dis aux chances des uns c'est pas
forcément ce que la proie dans la tête
vous voulez voir la croix voilà c'est
fort izon johan frégé du persan en
entend parler c'est tout cela qui ont
émergé
c'est leur
sésame en une seule star est ce que
c'est important franchement c'est très
bien qu'elle a déjà peur alors je songe
tout la règle du jeu
des audiences les audiences ce lancement
est à 4 millions si cela on est passé à
3 millions 8 battue par france 3 la
semaine passée un coup de l'homme reste
effectivement eu notre chance on va dire
absolument correcte mais effectivement
la descente a commencé et les gros
format bo1 quand même koh lanta mettant
marre des bas pour l'instant c'est une
cata en passant bien sûr millions
3 millions pour koh lanta
bon centre de voice ça marchait quand
même mieux bien sûr que j'en ai vraiment
début du problème quand on n'y aura plus
il ya dans cette direction d'erding dans
un sens pas mal ça 17 ans aussi c'est
pas clair
on